hello so I've got a bit of a life update
for you today it's a big one how do I
explain this I've been away travelling
which is why I haven't made a video in
like six months has it been longer maybe
a year I have a bit of trouble keeping
track of time these days
doctor what is your Wi-Fi connected to
the time rotor yes so I can upload this
to whatever day I like of course so
sorry it actually hasn't been that long
for you since my last video but it has
been quite a while for me basically I
met a man and he's taken me away with
him which is not what you think it is we
are just friends or at least I think
he's my friend he is a bit difficult to
read but he also hasn't kicked me out
yet so I mean to be honest I think if I
actually tell you what I've been doing
I'm pretty sure you're not gonna believe
me
but I also just I really need someone to
talk to so I think I'm just gonna do it
the man that I have been travelling with
is an alien and this is his spaceship
which is also a time machine so I know
what you thinking why am I still
subscribed to this lunatic but I swear
to you I'm not joking it's been a pretty
eventful trip to say the least I
probably should have brought my vlog
camera a bit more but I kind of wanted
to live in the moment well it's that and
then also whenever I do take the camera
out he tells me off for not paying full
attention to it that kinda makes you
stupid
you could you just not listen to me
while I'm doing this I told you it makes
me uncomfortable
sorry just putting some headphones or
something I want to say that I've been
having a really great time on this trip
because I have but turns out the
universe is also a bit dangerous either
that or he attracts it all this thing is
taking us to it on purpose because I
swear that every time we go somewhere
there is some new end of the world
crisis that seems to need a vertice mum
don't don't worry I'm I'm completely
fine safe hands and all that where have
we been so far in this trip
rexicoricophalvitorius bit smelly new
earth not quite as good as the original
in my opinion but still pretty great
barcelona the planet not the country Oh
16th century London I'm telling you
Romeo and Julia is only were see with
the original cars Gallifrey
wait what just kidding I know you still
listen in now so yeah sorry that this is
just sort of an update video I promise I
will have more interesting stuff for you
soon be sure you don't want to say hello
just tell them to subscribe to my
youtube channel okay you Adam see you
next time you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool bike
which makes you like cool thank you very
much for watching and thank you also to
the Doctor Who fan show for bringing me
to the TARDIS today that was quite a
nice of you we did film another video
today for their channel for the Doctor
Who YouTube channel so you can find that
over there as well as my previous video
and now I think I'm just gonna go and
play with this cuz it's here and right
as well eh